Oh so exci what do you do I work for  Kingsman the tailors - I must say you  are really not as I expected  yeah welcome back welcome to statement  independent intelligence agency as  American cousins how can I help  copy of us save the world situation here  thank you tie to the kingdom and if all  of the doomsday protocol  [Music]  how to make you wanna slap in mama right  there boy brains skills skipping-rope  it's a lasso whatever within the  Kingsmen tails shop in London maybe  you've heard of us  [Music]  today marks the beginning of a new age  but I'm going to show you basic pie to  the Kingsmen Chronicle a bit of a save  the world situation it welcome the  Statesman is your American cousins will  be working side by side  we've got brains skills skipping rope to  lasso whatever  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  it's very American  [Music]  manners make it man do you know what  that means  you